if you're tired of your bank ripping you
off click the link below to learn about
our sponsor current which is an awesome
alternative to dealing with big banks
I'll tell you more about them at the end
of the video we are in a hundred-year
global pandemic and our president is
dramatically miss handling it so I do
want to keep you apprised as to what
he's been up to for the last 72 or so
hours Donald Trump spent the weekend at
Camp David did a Fox News a virtual town
hall on Sunday night and then he
basically took yesterday off if you look
at Donald Trump's schedule from Monday
you find nothing on it and yet yesterday
was a really big day in a sense we are
fighting coronavirus we learned of
documents from the CDC and FEMA told you
about the documents earlier they predict
that we will spike to three thousand
American deaths a day by June first
hopefully not true but certainly
something to be taken very seriously we
found out states are rapidly running out
of unemployment money we found out that
states without enough social distancing
are starting to see large spikes in
cases on a percentage basis the numbers
may still be relatively small but
percentage-wise you are seeing some
times the case growth double from one
day to the next so we learned last week
that even when Trump does do work he
often is showing up at noon after
watching TV for five to seven hours a
day and sending out outrageous tweets
yesterday was a clear schedule except
for nearly 24 hours of Rage tweeting 6
a.m. to 1 a.m. ok I mean we're talking
about 19 hours of tweeting here all day
and night spent tweeting outrageous
attacks and untruth starting with
attacks on the press bright and early
saying quote con cast as he calls
Comcast should open up a long overdue
Florida cold case against psycho Joe
Scarborough I know him in crazy mica
well used them beautifully in the last
election dumped them nicely and will
stayed on the record that he is nuts
besides bad ratings so attack on MSNBC
at
two specific journalists media people
Joe Scarborough and Mika Brzezinski
three attacks it's like 6:30 in the
morning then Trump goes directly into
talking about his coronavirus ratings
another obsession saying quote getting
great reviews
finally for how well we are handling the
pandemic especially our strong
production of desperately needed
ventilators the building of field
hospitals and beds and soon the great
things we are doing on testing people
are really working well together
understand that 1,200 people died on
Sunday another bunch died yesterday and
Trump is tweeting about reviews ratings
and getting credit this is a very sick
person this is an acutely unwell
individual Trump bragging then about
something which actually has been a huge
accomplishment forum which is one of the
main reasons that it's an emergency to
remove him in November which is judges
Donald Trump tweeted yesterday
Republicans love the biggest tax cuts
rebuilt military choice for vets which
was an Obama program by the way saving
Second Amendment and many other things
my administration has done but what they
love beyond all else is 252 so far
federal judges not including two great
Supreme Court justices a big record
Trump is Right Trump in in collusion
with Mitch McConnell have put in place
judges hundreds of judges who will
decide law and cases for your children
and grandchildren in some cases that is
how long they are going to be in power
he is right about this one and he must
be stopped then Trump attacking
California saying Mexico is sadly
experiencing very big virus problems and
now California get this doesn't want
people coming over the southern border a
classic they are so lucky that I am
their president border is very tight and
the wall is rapidly being built so to
date to this point of the day he's
attacked MSNBC Joe Scarborough Mika
Brzezinski and California as well as
bragging about ratings then
again bragging about testing a favourite
topic and if Trump is talking about
testing you know he's lying he said
quote by Congress not wanting the
special five-minute testing apparatus
they are saying that they are not
essential in any event we have great
testing capacity and have performed 6.5
million tests which is more than every
country in the world combined remember
we have the receipts the United States
is currently 41st in testing per capita
globally
we're behind Canada but we're ahead of
Belarus we have 331 million people
testing six million means that after two
months of this we've only tested two
percent of the population what matters
is our testing rate not the number of
tests we are 41st in the world our death
rate on the other hand is the 14th
highest death rate in the world don't
take my word for it go look up the
numbers then later last night Trump
attacking MSNBC again but also CNN
tweeting MS DNC and fake news CNN are
going wild trying to protect China and
then this was really late last night it
was like 1:00 a.m. but it's so insane
I'm going to count it Trump very
triggered by a new political ad against
him with a multi tweet rant get a load
of this Trump saying this is this is
rage from a president in the middle of
the night it is very acutely unwell it's
a sign of Trump being ill saying quote a
group of RINO Republicans who failed to
badly 12 years ago then again eight
years ago and then got badly beaten by
me a political first-timer four years
ago
have copied no imagination the concept
of an ad from Ronald Reagan morning in
America doing everything possible to get
even for all of their many failures you
see these loser types don't care about
252 new federal judges two great Supreme
Court justices a rebuilt military a
protected Second Amendment biggest-ever
tax and regulation cuts and much more I
didn't use any of them because they
don't know how to win and their
so-called Lincoln project is a disgrace
to Honest Abe I don't know what Kelly
and did to her deranged loser of a
husband moon face but it must have been
really bad John Weaver lost big for
Kasich to me crazed Rick Wilson who's
been on this show lost for Evan McMuffin
McMullen to me Steve Schmidt and Reid
Galvan lost for John McCain Romney's
campaign manager lost to Big O and
Jennifer horn got thrown out of the New
Hampshire Republican Party they're all
losers but Abe Lincoln Republican is all
smiles the unintelligent eligible
rantings of a lunatic a triggered
lunatic so it's a day with nothing
scheduled for Donald Trump after his
weekend at Camp David riddled with
nonsense on Twitter during which he
attacked MSNBC CNN Joe Scarborough Mika
Brzezinski California
some Republicans Kellyanne Conway's
husband George Conway Republican
strategists Rick Wilson Steve Schmidt
Evan McMullen Mitt Romney's campaign
manager whose name he doesn't know and
Jennifer horn while bragging about his
coronavirus ratings and lying about
coronavirus testing this was just Monday
this was just Monday he also spent the
weekend rage tweeting with all sorts of
different claims including that
journalist Nicole Wallace was thrown off
of the view quote like a dog like a dog
that is the President of the United
States
thanks to 60 something million Americans
we must act in November
it's no secret on the show that I am
very critical of the big banks and how
they screw over customers in so many
ways and if you're like me you're
probably sick of the fees and the
hassles that come with a checking
account at a big traditional bank by now
in that case check out the online bank
current they're one of our sponsors if
you're watching on YouTube this here is
my actual debit card for my current
checking account which I'm holding up
with current you've got no minimum
balance no overdraft fees up to $100 no
ATM fees you can use over 55,000 ATMs
nationwide unlike with other banks you
receive your direct deposit instantly
meaning you'll get paid by your employer
up to two days sooner you can deposit
checks instantly using your camera phone
24/7 member support and unlike with
other banks current instantly refunds
that hold on your card when you pump gas
you can pause your debit card instantly
which is really useful there are just so
many different advantages to ditching
the big banks and instead use a bank
that puts their members first it takes
two minutes to sign up they'll
immediately ship you your debit card for
free go ahead and get started by
clicking the link down below the video